I'm really curious about what we can do
with narrative it's not it's not for
everybody but it's I think of it as an
album when you put on an album of music
you get you get a few things you get
hopefully a pretty good emotional
experience you get a sense that this is
something you either want to live with
or you don't and then at some point you
put it on again and maybe again and
after a while you come to find things
about it that were not obvious from the
get-go and you come to internalize that
work and then you know whether this is
something that's going to be long lived
or something that maybe isn't I mean I
think editing is just for this it was
just yet another way that we had to keep
informing of a more subjective
experience I mean the film actually
moved through I think you know different
narrative layers because we've got a
lead character that is starting in one
place ending in another but almost the
entire time questioning what the what
her appropriate narrative is and and
what what are these events that are
happening just off screen that are
somehow affecting her or poking her but
she can't speak to them and and so
because of that she's she's moving
through different different not
realities but narratives I mean
different personal narratives so
everything that we're doing has to
inform that and so we start off in a
very lockdown mode where most we're
using compositions and hopefully
hopefully interesting compositions but
mainly static shots to convey
information and then in the middle third
we get into a much more subjective space
where we are following Chris and Jeff
through seeing seeing how they are
reacting to events that we know of
transpired but they don't and you know
it almost approaches a found-footage or
a home movie mode in some places but the
idea to be able to just switch up
cinematic modes whenever we need to
based on what Chris's experiences I felt
like there we had the freedom to do that
and then the last third we get into
another space entirely where we're
dealing almost with nothing but subtext
and and will and it carry forward of the
momentum that's that's been building
there and so yeah when we traverse
different locations with match cuts I
mean Val of that stuff has to be very
well planned out in advance sorry you're
asking about the editing
yeah I mean it's it's just one of the
other things to to inform that and and
so David Lowery came on I was really
struggling to keep up and I was I was I
was um I was not keeping up basically I
I was losing more and more every day and
and it was affecting everything else so
he was nice enough to come in and I
didn't know what to expect but he
started putting things together
according to you know he did
internalized the film and internalized
what we had done so far and looked at a
some of my editing and just started to
just do a really thorough wonderful job
of matching that without ego and we
quickly got into a collaborative mode
where I came to trust him so much and
his ideas and he was starting to inform
the edit obviously himself and so I
would start during the day to shoot for
his edit and he'd be editing for you
know whatever notes I took for the shoot
and it was truly collaborative and then
at the end of shooting you know we were
able to work together
I'm concurrently and you know he'd be in
one room might be in the other and we
would just go back and forth much of the
music was written during the writing
process for the script
mainly so that I have some confidence
when I've got a moment that I'm
imagining in my head if I know what we
can do with with with the visual
language and I know you know the other
parts of the script if I have a piece of
music that I can I can get more or less
perfected for this moment then I know
okay great I can sort of swirly sit
together in my head and know we'll get
there and then I can start to build on
that so that's how it starts and then
before long I've got something that I
think of as the complete score and then
that starts to inform are the visual
language as we ramp up to production and
then you know Amy Simon shows up and and
shows how effective she's going to be in
the lead and then that says something
about the other elements so yeah the
music starts early and then it continues
to change depending on what it needs to
do and how the other departments inform
it and yeah and then they guess what the
soundscape and I mean that was something
that most most of what's going on in the
film as far as sound is in the script
and then there are other things where
this process that I'm I'm describing
that I think everybody probably knows
but whatever
I find myself describing it as if I'm
doing something new or something but
this this process you know before
getting into production where all of
these departments are figuring out how
they're going to work and there's the
storm of networking and in perfecting
things happen and so here's what I'm
trying to get to there's there's a scene
in the film where where Chris and Jeff
are both at work and they're lost in the
sounds of the workplace and then that's
though each of those sounds bleed into
each other they bleed into sounds in
nature where the samplers is and and you
know we're basically informing that
there is a there is a unknown connection
at work here
and we almost don't want to say any more
than that and that was event that was
originally going to be told through
visual cues we would we would you know
Chris would be having lunch downtown and
a small sculpture of a cityscape her
hand would inch closer and closer to a
certain building without her knowing it
we would push into a miniature of that
building match cut to the actual
building that jeff was working at and
then we would find another visual cue to
match back to her and it would all be
told silently and through visuals